- My mom shot my father and--
- [Interviewer] What happened?
- She shot my father and
killed him when I was a baby.
And that's why she did what she did
to me because I'm a spitting image of him.
- [Interviewer] So Benjamin
where are you from?
- I am from Detroit, Michigan, and--
- [Interviewer] That's my home town.
- Is it really?
I'm from seven mile and Gratiot.
East side.
I moved up there when I was 12
because the very abusive mother
and my best friend, his mom adopted me.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry,
what happened to your mom?
- My best friend's mom adopted
me away from my birth mother.
- [Interviewer] Why did
you leave your actual mom?
- She was, I don't even
want to say abusive,
she was a torturer, she was ridiculous.
She, psychological, emotional,
physical abuse, sexual abuse,
anything she could do to
cause my day to be harder
she packaged it up for me
and served it on a cold dish.
It was,
and when my friend's
mom found out about it
she was a paralegal and she got her firm
to take the case and fight it.
It took three years and they
they got me from them.
And I went from like a
literally a multi multimillionaire family
to a blue collar, inner city,
black family in Detroit.
It was like the opposite
of the Jeffersons.
You know what I mean?
It's about a lot of perspective
from both sides of it.
There's a lot of that yin yang with me.
I have a high IQ, but
a learning disability.
You know what I mean?
There's always a freaking
counterbalance or, or a caveat.
You know what I mean?
It's like, so it's made my
life interestingly difficult,
but made me appreciate it everything I got
because I've never had it handed to me.
I've had to struggle a little
harder than the next guy.
And I've gotten to where,
that's the only way I want it.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- I'll be 44 in June.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have any kids, girlfriend,
wife, anything?
- No, that's where it gets interesting.
I married my best friend growing up.
We knew each other since
we were two years old
we didn't get married 'til
we were in out twenties
but we had a daughter in '99.
She's 19 going to my own
alma mater OSU right now.
Five years ago, her mother
dropped Lena off at church,
and on her way, home picked
up some White Castles for us.
It was my one day off a week
and was hit head on by a
drunk driver and killed.
He was a fire chief, the
clinic's fire department.
He was on duty and he was schnockered and
that was the ultimate unfair thing
because I had it really good.
I had it better than I deserved.
Most people were like,
Figgins, you got a great girl.
You got, you got so lucky.
And I appreciated it.
We finished each other's sentences.
We were like that.
I still freaking go to tell her a joke
and no one else is going to get it.
And it leaves me freaking hollow.
And it's, I've got to swallow
it and say, you know what?
It's part of my path
but I really think that one was not fair
because I came home and
I was the guy, I worked,
I was the breadwinner.
My wife took care of the kid
took care of the house and the business.
And I tried to juggle it
for about a week and realized
I cannot raise a daughter,
who's 15 years old when I'm
working 14 to 16 hours a day
including my commute, six days a week,
she's going to be a latchkey
kid, completely unsupervised.
There's nobody nearby to help out.
So not only did I lose my wife
I had to give my daughter to my in laws.
And I lost both my girls
within a week basically
and my daughter never understood it.
She thinks I abandoned
her and she thinks that
I ran away to go party and
get high and say, fuck you.
And I tried to explain to
her a thousand times, Lena,
when you left and your mom wasn't there,
I sat in my house and it was just silent
and there was nothing.
And it was so depressing--
- [Interviewer] How far away
were your in laws from you?
- An hour and a half.
I was in a, if you're familiar with Ohio,
Athens County down by the Ohio river
everybody was in Columbus,
including my job.
I drove 90 minutes to two hours
each way to work everyday.
And I freaking sunk into the most brutal--
- [Interviewer] So your job
and your in-laws were in Columbus,
why didn't you just move to Columbus?
- Because I had recently
inherited my family home
that had been started by
my great great grandfather
built by hand
and every generation has
inherited it and added onto it.
And it's, I'm the last,
and it was important
to me to keep it going.
And I couldn't do that with
maintaining another property.
And, you know, we had just,
we've been established there about a year
and things were good and
I don't know, it just,
the logistics of it
just wouldn't work out.
I had, I kind of had to do it.
I was the only one,
it would have fallen
to pieces, if I didn't.
And I, so you know, I, I pretty much,
in sitting here now,
the last, last of my line
cut off from everybody.
And I came to LA
for a new start because I
didn't know anybody here.
And I had no ghosts or demons
and I can maybe create a fresh slate.
And you know what, it's
a curse and a blessing,
because I've never felt
I feel even lonelier here.
I rarely have met a couple people.
I can barely call anybody a friend here
because I use that word very seriously.
It's you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] What's the
story with the house now?
- Well, it kind of involves her,
around new years I found this dog.
She was unwanted and abused
and I was on my way to jump
off the fourth street bridge.
When I came across her
she distracted me because I
worked in an animal hospital.
I saw a dog in stress and I took over
and kind of rescued her from
out from under the vehicle.
She freaking leaped into my arms and just
she I've never seen a dog
thank somebody so much
and bond so quickly.
I forgot all about jumping off the bridge
focused on this thing
and said, you know what?
It's one thing for me to be out here.
It's another thing for a
Chihuahua to be out here.
I'm going to get you
off the streets sooner rather than later.
And department of mental
health came through recently
and got me in transitional
housing at the Russ Hotel.
And I think I'm a month or two away
from my semipermanent home.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- That'll be like an SRO for a year
and then that leads to my
the VA's gonna grant my permanent housing
which can go anywhere.
- [Interviewer] So do you
get a VA check every month?
- Yeah, it's I only have a 25% disability.
They don't accept my hearing loss.
I drove a tank and most
every 19 kilo tanker
has some hearing loss.
And now they just came out with
when we were in Afghanistan,
3m gave us defective,
knowingly gave us defective
hearing aid, hearing protection.
So that just adds to it.
But yeah I'm fighting them again
and they might play ball with me.
I just think my best bets just suck it up,
finish my last semester at school
and then go back to the workforce
and just make my own
way, like I always have.
- [Interviewer] So what
happened with the house in Ohio?
- Well, it was just so depressing there.
I had three or four suicidal attempts
after my wife and daughter left.
I started drinking a lot.
Self-destructing so I just had to leave.
I found a friend,
an old friend of the
family to live nearby.
They're being very nice and
going over there and checking
on it and making sure
everything doesn't go to pot.
- [Interviewer] You still own it?
- Yeah it's still titled to me,
it's out in the middle of nowhere
and I really don't know if I
could even get much for it out
there because it's, like I said,
with me driving so far,
there's no employment nearby
it's just so luckily the
property taxes are cheap.
It's somewhat self-sustaining,
it's on the last death throes
of an old oil well that were
drilled there years ago.
It's in coal country.
So there's lots of mineral
that kind of pays for like,
it breaks even pretty
much, working scenery,
throwing some solar in there.
I don't know we're looking
at if I get some back pay
from the VA, from this lawsuit,
but I might
I might just depending on what
the VA does in my settlement
kick it here until everything
gets settled with them.
And if I'm, if they're going
to go ahead and retire me,
I might just go there and retire.
And just, I think my
attitude's a lot healthier now,
and I would set myself up for some bumper
so I didn't go down like
that again, you know,
but I'd like to return there.
I love the peace and quiet
and the nature and it's good for me.
And I think without such
a horrible situation
I think I can embrace it
and give it a good honest shot.
I just like to find someone
to share it with, that's all.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] How are
you doing now with alcohol
and you're in the middle
of drug central here,
are you--
- I actually, and part of the deal,
with getting the housing is
this is housing for healthcare
kind of the triple H initiatives
that were passed two years ago,
it requires mental
health care, connections,
medical care connections,
primary care doctor,
regular visits,
linked up with them and
drug and alcohol counseling
and an active participation
in the program.
So right now I am
in twice a week intensive
outpatient drug program
at homeless healthcare
for the substance abuse,
a great caseworker.
They're a great team.
- [Interviewer] So what,
what drugs were you using?
- I was always opiates and marijuana
but that's I'm on like,
they call it medicated,
medically assisted therapy.
So I take Suboxone every day.
It's kind of a, kind of like
an abuses for alcoholics.
And it takes the withdraws away
prevents you from like
feeling any if you did use.
So it makes it futile.
You know what I mean?
It's pointless to use.
And it gives you that it
gives you what you don't have
at first and at the
early recovery, you know,
which is a Bulletproof vest.
So I can get my patterns established.
My connections established,
my routine established,
without having to worry
about kicking, physically and mentally,
one of the toughest
substances there is to kick.
It's something that's a hell
of a lot easier to wean off of.
So if I ever do want to move
off of it later, that's an option.
But right now everybody agrees.
This is the best thing.
And it seems to be working,
I'm giving them clean urines.
And that just something stupid
like that just makes me happy.
Like if it's something
I accomplished, I did,
and it was like, I'm attaining my goals,
and that's something I
haven't done in five years.
And then it makes me feel good.
And I think I'm scratching
and clawing my way back to
some sort of freaking light.
'Cause this almost got me,
the homeless thing almost got me to where
I was just this angry
muttering, spiteful, antisocial,
fucking this societal norms non-conformist
and just unwilling to participate
in society on any level.
And God let a little bit
of sunshine in and I just ran with it.
And I think I'm going to be much happier
if I build my life back
instead of just say it's over
and just let it go down the toilet.
- [Interviewer] That's excellent.
- [Benjamin] I've got over
a dozen suicide attempts,
including guns to my head.
I'm still here.
And there's no reason I should be.
So I've come to accept
that it's not my time.
There's a reason I'm not dead
because I had there's no
there's no explanation for it.
I absolutely, doctors are baffled,
my family's baffled,
anybody around is just like
how the heck did you get through that?
It's because there's
something on this earth that
I haven't done yet.
It's bigger than me.
I don't know what the hell it is.
Some sort of entity in the
universe has tasked me with
carrying some sort of
responsibility to this world.
And I think it's possibly
teaching somebody something
or possibly mentoring somebody.
So they don't have to take some
of the bumps and bruises I
did, but who the hell knows?
And I've sort of just said, okay.
And I've taken an approach
where I'm not actively
seeking it but keeping half an eye out
for those breadcrumb trails
of, okay, I think I get it now.
- [Interviewer] I think
you're onto something.
- My mom shot my father and--
- [Interviewer] What happened?
- She shot my father and
killed him when I was a baby.
And that's why she did what she did to me
because I'm a spitting image of him.
So I never met my father really
because I was an infant when he passed
I walk like him, talk like
him, same sense of humor,
and my mom having that guilt
she just used to be like--
- [Interviewer] She never got caught?
- Yeah, but let's put it this way,
this happened in the middle
of nowhere in the house
they just built.
Nobody knows what happened,
but her and my dad, and me,
but I was a year and a half old.
We were the only ones there.
My mother, she moved the body.
There was enough confusion
at the scene to where it wasn't,
it was the late seventies, you know,
the crime solving technology
wasn't what it is now.
And it looked like a suicide
and they didn't want to
you know as suicides that they
go with kid gloves and they,
they just kind of, okay,
and they left it at that.
And years later, I just
wouldn't give up on it.
And I dug at my grandmother and I said,
what the hell happened?
And she said, you know what happened.
She said, we covered for your mother.
Didn't want a tragedy to turn into two.
You're tire and rubber.
That's my grandfather.
Like he was president
of Goodyear and Allchin,
Blue blood, old money.
They didn't want a family
newspaper headline story.
And you know, it was swept under the rug.
That's how things were handled back then.
And when I pushed my grandmother,
she finally came clean,
and I pushed it.
- [Interviewer] Your
Grandmother being your dads mom?
- My mom's mom.
- [Interviewer] Your mom's mom?
- Yeah I,
it got as far as the prosecutor
the district attorney, looked at it,
took a really honest stab at a case
and just said, Benjamin,
there's too much hearsay.
You know how eye witness
accounts are anyway
and these are 40 years old and it's just,
I'm not going to win
this with a jury trial.
It's going to drag your whole
family through the mud anyway.
And you know what she won.
I'm sorry to say, I know what happened.
You know it happened, but we
can't get a case out of it.
So that's where it stands.
But you know, I'm just
glad I know what's up.
And like I said, my mother's
miserable, she's miserable.
She's paying for it.
- [Interviewer] How old is she now?
- Born in 52.
So yeah, she's in her late sixties.
She would have to--
- [Interviewer] So 66, 67--
- I think she's 67 in September.
Yeah she's still around.
I guess my daughter went and I told my kid
she happens to be living
three blocks away from her.
I said please don't be tempted to go
over to that lady's house.
I know you don't want to grow up
without your grandmother in your life.
That's not a grandmother.
That's something you
don't want to play with.
And Lena didn't get it.
And when I was unable to be
reached out here, off the grid,
on skid row, she went to my
mom and like, hey, where's Ben?
My dad is out of communication with me.
I need to know where he's at.
Do you have any information?
She told her I died of
drug abuse years ago.
And Lena mourned me and cried.
And that's her blood man.
That's her granddaughter.
And she made her cry and
thought nothing of it.
And when Lena got ahold of me again,
I said, I hate to say I tell you so dude,
but you're petting a snake
and you're going to be a bit
every time with Gail Hinshaw.
And she said okay dad, I cried uncle.
And I said, here's an email account.
I don't care what happens.
You can always find me
with this no matter what.
And she feels better with that now.
So no matter where we're in touch,
but we're mending a lot of broken pieces
of our relationship and it's
slow going, but it's there.
And I hope to see it come
all the way back one day.
But if by some chance
I'm able to be redeemed
at the end of my life here
on the last half of it
it would be so cool
because I've never gotten
a chance to do that.
I've never gotten
at the end to be smiling,
feeling satisfied.
I always bust my ass
worked to the top
and then get kicked
back down to the bottom
like Sisyphus and his rock.
And I'd like to
I think this is going to be my one shot
to hold the trophy up and say I did it.
I'm going to say I'm not going
to waste that opportunity
because they're obviously rare in my world
and I want to run with it.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- So I like to say we all
haven't seen the last of
me, big things coming.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- You're very well.